he was a very gentle soul he was an
incredibly loving caring dad a wall
painted with tens of thousands of hearts
each one
a life lost in this pandemic
this one belongs to safia's father dr
zahari na
he died in february last year at the
height of the second wave we actually
had to queue for the room where they
break bad news to patients because there
were so many families up there that day
we came out we had a chat with the
doctor
we understood what was going on and then
we went back in and they turned the
machine off
dr na came from malaysia to dedicate his
life to the nhs where he worked for
almost 40 years safia says the warnings
doctors and scientists are now sounding
about being overwhelmed remind her of
the messages she heard last winter take
the advice that were being given by the
nhs by the british medical association
and move to plan b and implement rules
we just need leadership and rules and
policy otherwise otherwise people will
die
a new delta plus variant is now being
investigated of concerns that it may be
more transmissible
some hospital trusts are visibly
struggling the royal cornwall hospital
has declared a critical incident
but there is one big difference to last
winter there's a vaccine and a booster
to support those whose protection might
be waning
and the government is sticking with its
plan a
trying to ensure anyone who can be
further protected
is the boosters are fantastic i mean the
the levels of protection are really very
high but it's also very very important
that you get one because the the double
vaccination
provides a lot of protection against uh
serious illness and death but it doesn't
protect you against catching the disease
and it doesn't doesn't protect you
against passing it on as cases rise
pressure builds even his own scientific
advisors on sage say encouraging people
to work from home is likely to be the
most effective way of making sure the
nhs doesn't become overwhelmed
and some of their colleagues on the jcvi
say the booster alone won't do every two
weeks the same number of people are
dying in this country of this infection
as were killed in the 911 uh um um
terrorist attacks in in america uh 20
years ago professor finn agrees that
vaccines save lives but he warns with 5
million people still to get the jab
other interventions are needed the
booster program is not some kind of
magic bullet that's going to bring the
problem of the pandemic to an end it's
just one part of a big jigsaw of
different things that will determine uh
how much how many cases we have how many
deaths we have and how much of a problem
we have for the nhs in the coming weeks
and months
safia doesn't want other families to
suffer the way hers has
if the government's vaccine gamble
doesn't pay off she fears
many more names
will be added to this wall
ashish joshi sky news in westminster